everyone
in the department is welcome to
participate we encourage you to do so um
the committee meets once a month and we
um rotate between
a um an event
and speaker like this and you may
remember that we had tiffany vino
present her research back in december
um and um some kind of journal club or
other discussion and then a working um
and administrative meeting
and when we have this meeting we um
when it's the month for this meeting we
put it into the research conference time
slot to make it more convenient for
people the other meetings take place on
thursdays at
um
4 p.m uh once a month and if you're
interested in joining the committee you
can
ask
you can send an email to myself or paul
gorman or lynn schwabe and we'll get you
connected into the committee um so it uh
it gives me great honor uh to uh
introduce our speaker today who
many of you know
um dr george maycano who's the senior
associate dean for education in the
school of medicine so he oversees all of
the
educational mission of the school
including our graduate program
and
we've asked him to come today because he
has been involved in at the school of
medicine level
developing the school of medicine
strategic plan
for diversity equity inclusion and
anti-racism which he's going to talk
about
he's also going to make some um comments
about the covington report
and the goal of this session is to
um for us to hear what's happening at
the school level how we can integrate it
at the department level and um i presume
he'll leave time for questions and
discussion uh people can ask questions
and so forth um just to give a brief
introduction um dr mejicano and i have
uh
followed a somewhat um similar path uh
growing up uh in uh chicago
um and um uh training in medicine at the
university of illinois uh college of
medicine actually doing undergraduate at
in champaign-urbana illinois
although during my training i interacted
more with his older brother
who i did my residency at university of
illinois hospital with
george has so george trained in internal
medicine and infectious diseases he's
been involved in a lot of efforts uh
with um
education
uh particularly at the um
undergraduate medical education level he
was the pi um or is the pi of our
grants from the american medical
association to accelerate change in
education
um he also has a master's degree in
adult education
and spent a number of years at the
university of wisconsin
before he came to ohsu
and so i will turn the floor over to him
and
ask him to take it away thank you george
um thanks bill and paul for uh asking me
to come and speak um i'm gonna actually
go through uh
some ver three very brief powerpoints um
and really hope to at least have half an
hour of discussion
um
and as as bill framed it um i i was i
had a
major role with regards to the new
school of medicine diversity
uh equity inclusion anti-racism
strategic action plan and
um and then paul did ask me also to talk
about
the covington report so with that uh let
me launch into to this and
i can send the slides to all of you so
um no no worries about that at all
um okay so um
my partner in crime here so to speak is
leslie garcia but there's been a lot of
other people involved as well
um modia
minowin and many many others
so um
uh
the
school embarked on creation of a new
action plan um and as you can see here
in the circle um
that this is
basically a road map if you will for the
next five years
um and
through up
inclusive process that the committee
took uh the diversity affairs committee
of the school took on um we embraced the
these tag words of belong include and
empower
let me first talk about how the plan is
organized
um the plan uh the idea is it's a single
plan for the entire school of medicine
but we must align with university-wide
efforts and and dr jacobs has said that
the good the
university must become an anti-racist
multicultural organization
and so underneath that overarching plan
the the structure is that we have three
goals also known as timeless aspirations
and the analogy i'm using here is one of
direction so in other words what's our
true north so the three goals basically
to tell us which direction we need to go
and each of those three goals underneath
them has actually
um three object three objectives so a
total of nine objectives and you can
think of that using that same analogy as
the distance we're going to travel in
those directions
um and then uh underneath each of those
are tactics so there's a total of 79
tactics
and you can think of that as the method
by which we will travel that distance in
that direction so uh again just the
overall structure one big plan
three goals nine objectives 79 tactics
and there is an expectation that each
department center and institute
will create a unit level plan that will
essentially align with the school of
medicine's overarching plan because uh
as
uh as if you look at each of the tactics
you'll see that some will be frankly
more germane to some departments versus
others and demise as bill has pointed
out to me many times is a very unique
department um sort of in the twilight
between clinical and and and basic
science um and so i can imagine that
some of these will be extremely relevant
to you and some will be
not much but not very little relevance
to you so um
and again this is sort of an overarching
structure piece so there's our three tag
lines belong including power and
um uh underneath them the three
objectives so
um and we're going to go through each of
these uh in turn
so
here are our three directions or three
timeless aspirations
so under the tagline of belong the idea
here is that the school is going to
create and foster a learning and working
environment and i want to emphasize both
the learning environment and the working
environment
and that we welcome celebrate and
support all learners staff faculty
leaders and community members especially
persons from marginalized groups who
historically are underrepresented in
medicine in the biomedical sciences
so the idea here is really one of of
making sure that we um
uh
have
create a space and a place where people
want to come they want to belong or they
feel that they belong here um and notice
that it's not just about faculty and
staff it includes all the learners but
it also reaches out into the community
the second goal
with the tagline of include
is is really about what i would call
academic and professional
and career advancement
and so the school will recruit
admit hire mentor support retain
graduate advance and promote
individuals who are representative of
the increasingly diverse population of
oregon in the nation
so the idea here is not only do we want
people to feel welcome here we want
people to succeed here to thrive here
and so that's why there's all those
words it's not just enough to recruit
for example diverse graduate students or
that or diverse faculty or staff members
we want to make sure that they have a
pathway
that
they will get promoted they will advance
in in whatever career uh or component
they're involved with in the university
and then finally the third one is really
about shared power or shared governance
and the idea here is that the school of
medicine will commit to achieving
a more just and equitable world by
embracing a social mission
that leverages its resources and
expertise to aid underserved populations
and reduce health disparities
um and so these three can these timeless
aspirations in many ways are unreachable
um or they're they're definitely
on the stretch dimension these are gonna
be hard
uh uh and we the committee
uh purposely
wanted to sort of push the school to try
to do better um and so that's why it has
the language that it does in particular
the third one
by explicitly
calling out the us the social mission
that we are here for um it's not just
the academics right or the or the
education research missions um uh or the
clinical mission but we actually have a
social mission and i think a good
example of of how the university's work
is
manifesting that is with the vaccine
equity work uh to try to get vaccines
especially in populations who are
under resourced and marginalized
so those are the three directions or
again timeless aspirations so let's go
through into a little bit more detail
for each one of these so this the first
one that the goal of the the first goal
of belonging
um and um i'm not going to read through
each one of these these bullets but you
can see the organization here so so the
three objectives um under uh um beneath
that or that support uh that timeless
aspiration uh the first one focuses on
education and training and then there's
one of engagement and then there's one
of enrichment i'm going to just pull out
a few of the phrases here
um and the idea here is that
um we need to do a lot more professional
development so that includes things like
unconscious bias training bystander
training things like that but also
frankly things on on
relative to theory and practice around
around diversity that's everything from
um
uh best practices in in in from you for
hiring managers
to frankly whether or not we should
eliminate standardized testing up for
all of our admissions process the
graduate studies as most of you know
graduate programs
essentially have said the gre should not
be used uh the question is whether on
the md program for example should we
actually um eliminate the mcat that's an
example of of of of
realizing
the issues of bias around standardized
testing and then doing something about
it but the idea here is we need to learn
more about this we are um
uh
i would say
we're moving from unconsciously
incompetent to consciously incompetent
in terms of our knowledge base
around dei and a issues
the second one is really about
engagement
um and then again we want to we want to
make sure that that everyone feels that
they belong right that's the the tagline
here's belong
and that means that we need to
um uh make sure that we support all all
the members um and look at it from an
equity lens and amplify their voices
um and so that means everything from
like
representation on committees um is just
one example of that
uh and then finally um we need to also
um think about sort of celeb that's
celebrating and so i applaud you that
you that you uh and focusing attention
so i applaud you that you're using a
research conference on a quarterly basis
as an example um to
enrich the conversation through a dei
lens
so under the second goal of inclusion
this really is about
both driving numbers but also making
sure that people thrive there you'll
notice that there are 20 separate
tactics related to recruitment uh and we
want to
um absolutely diversify um the the all
the different groups at ohsu
uh but you'll see the second one is
really about making sure that we retain
them um you know how leaky is our
pipeline so to speak uh or said
differently um are we if we if we
recruit um say for example an
african-american faculty member uh do
they actually stay um and is their
retention rates the same as as somebody
else and another someone from another
different category
and
you got to do this with fuel meaning
resources all right and so we need to
make sure that that um the that these
efforts are appropriately funded uh to
move this work along and that's a tall
order because what we've done at ohsu
arguably
is we've talked a pretty good talk but
we've not put the resources in to really
um
move things move things forward that's
everything from scholarships
to
support of our interest groups employee
resource groups things like that
and then finally the third goal of
empowerment that's it
it's broken up into enable
really helping enable
groups and this is i get the idea here
is that
um
really about system issues right how do
we actually look at the structural
issues um
to make sure that um
things are in place that
that um
that we eliminate barriers in a
systematic manner and that we look at at
our structures and systems and so that's
better i'll just give you one that's
related to women but uh but it's but
it's a it's a good example which is
um
is is time to degree or time to
promotion
different if you have uh if there's
expectations um for example around um
uh other kinds of of familial or social
responsibility uh based upon um your on
one's culture uh and so should there be
different clocks for example for for
time to degree that's an example of of
looking at our structures and systems
the second one here is really about
making sure that we are engaging with
the community and that that is really
we we
frankly need the help of the community
right there's this in quality
improvement in in the clinical setting
there's this phrase that says nothing
about the patient without the patient uh
well i would argue that we should we
have to we cannot be in an ivory tower
here we have to be community engaged um
and that's everything that includes the
research mission uh for example
participatory research and um um uh for
example in rural areas
and then finally we need to make sure
that we evaluate our effort this should
be a cqi process um and and
have this be data driven the tactics
that we're making progress on that's
great celebrate those the ones we're not
making progress uh why is that um and
and to try to be nimble um in this
five-year
um
the the
well it's a it's more than a five-year
journey but but this plan for five years
um so this just uh just to give you some
timelines here that the diversity
affairs committee endorsed the planets
in september the faculty council adopted
it in november and it was approved by dr
jacoby as the interim dean that same day
and so we are in the process of of doing
the bottom part of the slide uh we're
going to create a diversity alignment
team to coordinate and implement the
plan both with cdi and other efforts
across the university including the
covington stuff but also um the
departmental plans
um we need to add frankly specifics to
each of the tactics so things like the
metrics
how will we know we've achieved things
um we're socializing and disseminating
and that's one of the reasons i'm here
is to do just that uh we'll be creating
a dashboard
to track and show our progress um and
again each department will is expected
to create their own unit level plan uh
and um here's again a bunch of resources
and hopefully all of you saw recently
leslie sent out a a new diversity
newsletter and so that's that's an
example of of the kinds of of things
that we'll be doing um you know going
forward so lots and lots of of
concurrent efforts but we need to also
move forward
so
that that's the
relatively quick uh overview of the
diversity action plan i'm going to
switch now to
a very brief powerpoint about the
covington report um
and then again i'd rather have a
dialogue than be just talking to all of
you
so with that let me
switch now to
this other presentation here
and paul dub you shared this but i'm not
sure who
um
is that correct
paul
i did not share it yet i was waiting for
you to present it okay perfect great
okay so um i created this
for the diversity affairs committee um
uh because we needed to have a forum to
talk about the covington report
so this is a high-level view of the
covington report
and i have to do a content warning for
all of you
because this
this small deck contains topics that
could be activating for survivors of
racial or gender or ethnic violence
um and uh so please take care of
yourself if you have to
you know walk away or turn off the the
video feed that's perfectly okay
be safe that's that's very important
so
as all of you hopefully know the
covington investigation was prompted by
concerns
related to both gender and racial
discrimination um uh and and there were
multiple incidents the the jason
campbell stuff was the
i would say the the the biggest one um
but there were other ones as well like
for example the findings of news is on
campus um uh were
examples and so because of that
the board of directors decided to
undertake a broad review of the
university's institutional culture and i
want to make sure people understand that
this was not a decision by dr jacobs
this was not a decision by cdi this was
decision by the board of directors of
the entire university
and they were looking at it not just for
what happened in one incident but they
really were looking at cultural issues
and that's really important to
understand because
although some of the recommendations
provide i would say
a pretty clear path forward about what
needs to be done
the underlying piece really is about
culture
and
that's really where i think the heavy
lifting needs to occur
so you know to do this the university
retained um a law firm that has some
very um
uh well-known luminaries including the
former attorney general of the united
states eric holder
and in italics you can see that the
investigation
was going to look at inequitable
treatment discrimination harassment
bullying
or intimidation based on race color
religion national origin disability age
marital status
sex including pregnancy sexual
orientation gender gender identity or
gender expression
and they were going to look at
policies procedures and practices
and to see if they were frankly designed
to ensure that people are being treated
equitably and that context was being
prevented
and really look at us compared to best
practices across
the the country
uh and so the report was publicly
released um and i mean it's an important
step it wasn't it wasn't hidden uh just
a quick aside seattle children's um uh
you may have heard had a very similar
um investigation by covington and their
board of directors actually tried to
bury it
they tried to actually not they actually
only gave like a um
an overview
uh and um it led to some heads rolling
up because of that so at ohsu
the board of directors said no this
should be released and released publicly
so everyone sees what they what uh
holder and company had to say
and
the report starts and frames things by
looking at our culture challenges
uh and these are frankly pretty
depressing comments um but i believe
them to be true they each one of these
resonate with me i was not surprised by
any of this
but it's important to say them out loud
so
we as a university have failed to create
an environment which community members
feel
values
diversity equity inclusion
and makes them feel welcome and safe in
other words there are people walking
around working on at the university of
some for decades um and it's not a safe
place it's not a welcoming place um and
frankly we do not
collectively value
we act in a way that does not value this
and the second one is that community
members being ohsu members report
differing experiences based on protected
characteristics status or position in
other words staff are treated for
example different than faculty men are
different are treated differently than
women uh people who are white are
treated differently who than people who
are hispanic uh and so forth and so on
um
in other words there are different rules
for different people and i think most
people
if you look at if you think about this
honestly that will resonate with you it
is certainly i've been here for almost
10 years that has certainly been my
experience
at ohsu
the third one
is that there
are
there's a perception of significant risk
and very little benefit of reporting
misconduct
primarily because you put your head out
on you know your neck out if you will
and yet nothing seems to change um
and so
there we have a very big problem this is
the exact opposite of a culture of
safety where people feel that they're
empowered to to point out problems to
improve
the fourth cultural piece is that the
community members believe that ohsu does
not hold people equally accountable that
that's related to number two
um but now we're talking about you know
high stakes accountability do people get
you know lose their jobs or get get
reprimanded etc and so may some of you
may have seen that in fact we do
reprimand um and we do dismiss more
people of color proportionally than than
people who are
in majorities uh you know white males in
particular
and then the fifth one is that the
community perceives that ohsu tends to
view reports of miscot misconduct with
skepticism and doubt in other words
um you raise concerns and you're the one
that get um gets uh questioned not the
person who
um
uh uh what was alleged to do something
so these are our big cultures these are
heavy lifts
so that's those were the underlying
cultural issues what did they actually
find
and i like the part in parenthesis at
the top these flow from contribute to or
exacerbate the cultural challenges
the findings include that our actions
and communications with respect to dei
mishkanic and human resources
are not aligned with our stated values
the second one is that we have not
established clear priorities
an institution-wide strategy to drive
change or policies that effectively
address dei in other words some people
think that oh that's cdi does that work
we don't do that work
um and we don't even know what that work
is
uh you know writ large
uh we're basically
it's not even
i would even say it's not even
coordination cooperation i think we're
antagonistic sometimes with regards to
this
the third is that the policies and
procedures addressing misconduct are
inconsistent and lack clarity and
precision
um and just to give you an example there
are multiple remote reporting mechanisms
so who do you call do you call aao or
title ix or the confidential advocacy
program or hr
um
and that that's that's a certainly a big
big problem
number four is that there's um the
university lacks a consistent process
for addressing and documenting concerns
um
uh and that the we don't close the loop
and so
employees are dissatisfied um and the
outcomes are not always fully informed
or effectively implemented and in fact
hiring managers and chairs and division
heads and center directors could
actually ignore for example the
recommendations from aaa or hrhr
and
we have not
put our money where our mouth is at and
that's what the fifth one's about we've
devalued and marginalized human
resources um we don't we have not
provided the resources the leadership um
and the authority um to them
and for an institution with essentially
19 000 employees that's a very big
problem
so
from these cultural
flash points and these findings here are
the recommendations
they're broken up into three themes tone
from the top
resources and staffing and policies and
procedures so tone from the top
to affirm
um
a resolute commitment to dei and a
in other words you have to say from the
very top we are committed to do this
work and you have to mean it
and therefore we have to elevate that um
throughout the entire institution
um and so it has to reflect in our
policies our practices and our cultures
and our governance processes
uh and we need to strengthen
accountability uh so that people really
understand the consequences of this and
then and how important they are um with
regards to expectations so that's a
that's basically saying
that the leadership has to buy in
um and then there's a bunch of resource
pieces these are what i would call more
the transactional stuff we have to
frankly do a nationwide search for a
leader for human resources
um
we also have to
centralize functions i'll just give you
a concrete example that some of you know
um for for many many years the head of
human resources for the school of
medicine reported to the dean um not
anymore all right so the human resources
apparatus if you will goes directly to
to human resources and does not report
to david jacoby now um and um and and
cerilda has already started this by
assigning basically two hr business
senior business manners managers kendra
sites and and fiona canova uh to that
role to to being the liaisons but they
don't report to david
jacoby the third one um is basically
provide more investigators and people
who
who are trained uh and who do it
consistently um and uh restructure
increase and diversify the staffing in
those units
and then in terms of policies and
procedures uh be very clear about what
is expected and what's prohibited um and
how the university will address such
misconduct
re streamline and revise the reporting
structures uh and the investigational
procedures
streamline the channels listed in
policies and guidance documents about
reporting
strengthen mandatory reporting
provisions so that everyone knows if
you're in this kind of job you have to
report this
these kinds of actions and activities
um and then finally um make sure that
there's non-retaliation provisions in in
those pnps
so um where is this uh the university um
has committed to dr jacobs and um and
the board expects this but dr jacobs has
committed that there will be transparent
communications about these findings and
recommendations
the university cabinet did in fact
discuss this
and um they've set into motion um um the
action steps that are are going forward
and so
there's going to be there's an
implementation committee that already
has has started to meet that's chaired
by alice cooper komas and susan bakewell
sax
um and uh there's gonna be an oversight
committee and that's gonna be co-chaired
um by um uh two essentially outsiders um
uh
um
i'm blanking out on the purse the one
the one one of the persons used to be
the head of the urban league of portland
i forgot his name and then the other
person is alicia moorland kapoor who
used to be a faculty member but now
she's at harvard uh and the the the
diversity affairs committee of the
school has all we've already been
discussing this we're looking at how
that the action plan needs to change um
and we want to better coordinate with
cdi
and with that
i think i'm right on time here i'm going
to stop sharing and really
uh just have a conversation with all of
you
around these two initiatives um
um
this is really important work
uh and i and uh i hope all of you take
this seriously and that you all
each of us does
reflects on what we can do better
individually as well as collectively
so with that bill i will open it up to
see if there's comments questions
um
yeah thanks thanks george um that um
that that's a a tremendous effort that
many people have put forth in this and
that we as an institution have needed to
do
let me just ask um you know as we always
do people can either unmute themselves
to ask questions or
type them into the chat
well i guess maybe i'll i'll ask one
question um
certainly um by the committee that we
have in our department there's a lot of
interest in enthusiasm in doing this
um one of the concerns that has been
brought up
is um
how how integrated this is with other
efforts should we as a department
be reinventing things are there um
ways we can collaborate with other
departments with the dean's office
others around the institution
to develop plans so we're not
necessarily um
starting from scratch
it's a really important piece because as
you know bill um you know a lot of the
departments have
functioned in
either autonomous or semi-autonomous
manner
um and
um we certainly would not want to put a
damper on on sort of innovation
creativity and what i would say you know
ground um
uh
actions that are occurring from the
ground up and so if
if demise for example said well we're
really interested in um
um
well your ex but your expertise in
epidemiology right so we want to do
something based upon that um in terms of
raising our research portfolio for
example we would want you to have that
the freedom
uh to to do that but what we would hope
is that it aligns with the
with the
school's action plan uh which which
broadly basically which probably says
that more research on diversity should
be should occur right as one of the
tactics so so as long as the alignment
is there we don't want to micromanage in
any way
so that's i think really important and
so
the the
the next steps um and by the way i i
don't think we're going to change the
action plan very much based on covington
i think it will just reinforce a few
things um but but i expect that sometime
in in the march to june period we expect
each department to start rolling up
their sleeves
um and creating their own um a device
specific action plan like i mentioned at
the beginning so
so um think about like venn diagrams
what we don't want is we don't want a
circle that's completely outside you
know never intersected with anything we
wanted to intersect
with the with the school's plan
um
that's with regards to
dei and a activities um
broadly speaking the covington stuff is
going to be i think much more
centrally managed
um and
we're gonna
that's gonna be driven by by the
implementation uh committee that susan
and alice co-chair so i do think that
that's going to be driven like things
like human resource restructuring um
staffing of aaeo
policies and procedures around who's a
mandatory reporting that's those are
going to be central processes
does that make sense
yeah sure that does and uh um i will uh
turn over the floor to chris alpy the uh
ohsu librarian who is also a d mice
faculty member hi chris hi so the
question i really have is about how you
see the school of medicine's plan
fitting into the rest of the university
plans at um the school kind of levels or
if you think about all the different
learners who are in interaction with
everybody in the school of medicine
that's going to be
engaged towards working towards this
planning goals you know how does this
look for
interprofessional engagement you know
what you know how is the school of
medicine's plan interfacing with the
school of nursing or with the provost's
office given that we have a new provost
coming
um
do you have a sense for how the this
situates for learners with those large
with those other entities there's kind
of this leadership gap between not gap
but level between the president and the
board and the school of medicine that
our learners experience from many of the
issues on here and i just wondered if
you could speak to that sorry that was
long-winded no it's a it's a good
question it's a complicated area um um
i'll i'll try to get at it but i think
this is this is an um
trying to find the right way of saying
this
part of the problem is as with with
patience
and
um
the balance between being reflective and
thoughtful and action-oriented
um and so we we talked a lot about this
with the the diversity affairs committee
um and uh
um modia who was the prior chair before
meena
mo and myself and leslie had many
conversations around around this issue
you'll see where i'm going in about a
minute um
and
you know the school of medicine some of
you may be acutely know or maybe acutely
aware of this is sometimes accused of
basically
acting unilaterally
and essentially not being patient with
the university to move things forward
and there's a desire in some cases to
because we
we feel an urgency
to move things forward and chris as the
librarian and the the are
the chief of the library i think you've
you've seen that and felt that um i
would be surprised if you hadn't felt
that
so that's there's that tension of how do
you sort of
get in get in sync with university
efforts and especially the provost's
office or the health system
and yet also
be accountable and responsible to move
things forward um and so so the big
piece there i think is about
communication and making sure
that
people are engaged and and that you're
clear about everything going forward and
i'll give you a very concrete example
about the action plan so i i personally
kept dr jacobs abreast of the of our
the school's
proposed diversity action plan
um the governance process by which it
was going to be approved or not approved
um and
i actually asked him like should we stop
should we delay
you know
and not and wait
and the response was no you should you
should proceed just make sure you're
coordinated
um and so
it's all of us working together and so
derrick to vivier was i kept him abreast
of where things were going um human
resources the same thing and so
i think the there's there's a long way
of saying
um
don't wait
but just make sure you're checking in
with this with different stakeholders
now with regards to i'll give you a a
concrete example with regards to um
educational
uh pieces right um and so as as
um
the people involved with the graduate
programs know we we've been pushing
really hard to try to diversify
the
our graduate
students
at ohsu
there's no reason to delay those efforts
and whether it's with
looking at our admissions processes
looking at mentoring looking at
where we recruit um
certainly that would be true bill for
faculty hiring practices things like
things on those lines we know those are
going to be in line with the with what
the university is going to want to do so
we should proceed with best practices um
um
and so it's a sort of a squishy way of
trying to respond to
don't wait but coordinate
does that answer your question chris
yes and it rhymes i like that don't wait
just coordinate really catchy
um i'm gonna do a couple one other thing
here bill well we're waiting for other
questions to see if there are questions
i'm going to put um
the link uh to
the new school of medicine diversity's
the updated school of emergency school
of medicine diversity site and if you
click on that link um
you'll there's a lot of information
there but right in the middle you'll see
the actual plan so people want to read
the entire plan they can click there for
the link and they can get all the 79
tactics
and i see jim's got his hand up hey jim
hi george thanks this is this is really
impressive and i note in particular that
it emphasizes uh culture change
uh and although policies and procedures
are always very important
when it comes to culture change people
um and you know at the front lines are
asking what's in it for me but they're
also looking
to the behaviors and actions that their
leaders take uh and
that places a special responsibility on
on leadership not that we all don't have
special responsibility but
what what should the leadership be doing
what what how they need to be seen they
need to be heard and they need to be
doing things that are are consistent
with
uh our aspirations here
what are your thoughts on that
i think you're muted george
sorry uh it's a great question and i
know you and i have had conversations
about organizational change management
and you know that i'm a believer in
cotter's theory so um
uh for those who don't know there's a
you know
john cotter basically has a theory on
how to drive organizational change
management um
so
so
um
i'll give you a couple of pieces just to
give you an example because this is
really happening
so one of the one of the issues around
being a truly anti-racist multicultural
organization is to be acutely aware um
in a front of mind
issues are related relative to trauma to
be to have a sort of a use a
trauma-informed systems perspective with
regards to these kinds of things and
that as an example that's why i put the
the content warning um slide the
beginning of the of the of the covington
conversation uh or
slide set um
and um
uh every member of the university
cabinet um actually went through a
two-day training
um and i can vouch for it it was seven
hours both days
uh um and it was run actually out of
alicia
um moral and capua's
shop at mclean which is one of the
harvard system hospitals
um
and it was eye-opening um about the
about
how trauma is propagated
uh and
i'll give you just one example you know
a lot of people say like we'll just
assume good intentions
right assume people are
are trying their best
well if you've been traumatized
um
that's not necessarily a safe assumption
to make right
uh and so
so how do we
have these conversations and how do we
and how do we create policies
um that they're truly trauma informed
so that's an example where the
leadership
um uh
was expected and did participate in
external training uh to to learn and be
more informed about about how to address
these kinds of um these kinds of issues
because we're because we're not all at
the same place we're not the level
the field is not but has not been level
set
so
so that's an expect
an example and so i do think
it's almost like the opposite of of of
six sigma where there's like lots of
green belts and a few black belts in
this case it's like the leadership has
to be
maybe not black belt but maybe brown
belt or orange belt uh the leadership i
think has an obligation to frankly learn
more about this
um than other groups and and to be and
to be exemplars with regards to this um
and so
um that might definitely
look like you know having discussion
forums um around misogyny right or
um
you know
words that can they can make their hair
on and stand on and in certain parts of
the country but like critical race
theory and things like that
so that's a that's an example of of of
ex
increased expectations for leadership
i think that i think the second or an
additional part personally
um
is frankly up is to apologize
um
there's psychological healing in my view
in my experience um
in in
not just reflecting on one's own
um
responsibility around things that have
occurred but also
um
things that didn't occur like about you
know in catholicism
there's there we talk about sense of
commission and sense of omission
and i and i think there's a there's a
sort of that personal accountability
piece because right now in my view i i
don't know if you and the other faculty
members and other people that are here
would agree with this but
um i think one of our biggest problems
is that our trust is basically in the
basement
maybe in the
ground underneath the foundation of the
basement you know
uh it's that low uh and so
so you have to start with with
relationship building and part of that
is is is apologizing and and you know
what have we done individually and
collectively to propagate things and
i'll give you there's many examples but
there's everything from like gender
um
um salary mismatch um as an example uh
otherwise known as pay equity
uh but there's uh but there's there's
also things around you know the
promotion practices um there's things
around um
uh
um
general mistreatment of different groups
on campus and and i i i certainly have
have played a role in that and i'm
profoundly sorry for that and
that it needs to start with that kind of
mentality i think almost a humility of
it um you know in 12-step programs
the first thing you have to say is that
you know
i i have a personal responsibility to
this
so i think that's the second part and
then the third part and i'll try to make
this quick but it's a lot really
complicated area um the third part is
um
that
we can't settle for transactional change
we have to embrace transformational
change
that's hard hard hard work
um
and um
it's gonna be frankly tortuous
uh um
not to be too dramatic here but i i
encourage all of you to read lincoln's
second inaugural address
um where he says
i mean the famous words are there with
you know with with males towards nothing
charity for all etc etc but the part
before that was
you know if
if um the blood
um from
uh the bondsmen you know whipping slaves
has to be repaid by the blood of bullets
and swords so be it and it's i'm
paraphrasing here
i think there's something to that
thanks george um i i think you were
really right about trust
and uh
that's hard work but it needs to be done
yeah joanne i think you have your hand
raised yes
hi um
i teach a course in ethics
and one of the things that
comes up occasionally i should say more
often than not when we talk about
research ethics and
diversity
students have been
more than honest about their concerns
related to
how they've been treated either
universally or specifically
at the university
and
it's usually a free-fall flow discussion
i give my comments as well
but i have been more concerned about and
we talk about trust this is what kind of
generated this concept in my mind the
the trust issue around when a student
does talk about these things
how much further as
um
individual instructor should i take the
comments that they've made which are
within the context of the course but
perhaps
um
indicate that they they have been hurt
in some way by the institution
or whatever and so um i'm wondering if
you could reflect on that how much
responsibility do we take we're not you
know i'm not a psychologist so i i don't
know um to what level you you um raise
the issue
and uh what my responsibility is to the
individual students sometimes i have
i have emailed them individually and
that i've i picked up on something and
i'm concerned about it what you know
what can i do for you or something like
that but um
it's been um tickling me more and more
as i'm i'm teaching the course to a more
diverse student population
and i'm wondering if you could please
reflect on
what your recommendations would be
i appreciate the comment in the question
um
i'll give you my personal perspective on
this but i think this is going to be we
need to have further dialogue um but
i'll tell you where i am with this so i
consider myself a mandatory reporter um
um and so whenever there is a learner
involved whether it's a student or a
resident a fellow postdoc et cetera
whatever there's a learner
um that's involved and if there's an
issue of mistreatment or abuse or
um harassment et cetera et cetera i
i automatically elevate it
i have submitted
dozens and dozens and dozens of of
um
uh reports to um integrity
um
and
in my
first nine years here at ohsu i i
thought i had a pretty good pretty good
sense of like oh this goes to hr this
goes to title nine this goes to aau
um etc but that's gonna be streamlined
so my sense is it will probably be more
of a one-stop shop for reporting
um we'll see what what the what the
covington implementation committee comes
up with but um but my point here is is
that i have a very low threshold um it's
such a non-existent threshold i i
escalate this
all the time
and
i think there's a real fear or
maybe that's the wrong word um
a concern maybe twin concerns one is
it's none of my business or i only know
one piece of this
and
uh and then the second one is um
i'm not sure that the person that's
who's who has shared this information
would want me to do this
uh and um
i will i will tell you based on my
experience and looking at a lot of data
on mistreatment of both residents and
students
um is that um
we have a toxic culture
and so
i escalate
i always escalate this and
and um i i liken this maybe this is
maybe this is inappropriate
uh all of you will judges make have
opinions about about what i'm about to
say but i liken this to hearing about
about elder abuse or child abuse in the
clinical setting
all right um
to me they're they're
this is we have an obligation to to
to bring these things to life
and since this is demise and there's a
bunch of epidemiologists on the faculty
um
i look at this as surveillance
right this is public health surveillance
and
that doesn't mean that every accusation
or allegation is
true
there needs to be due process and
substantiation and all that kind of
stuff um but um
we should not be shy in
in
raising the concerns
i do have cons
having said that i do as an educator
have
some uneasiness
around
guilt by
popularity or
maybe they said differently guilt by um
being tried in the uh in the court of
public opinion as opposed to
a a good investigation but i think if
our systems are in place
with solid investigatory
skills
um and personnel then then
my concern that will really fall to the
wayside
um but but at this point
i
my two cents to you just my opinion um
is i would report all of it
um we're going to get more clarity about
this
about mandatory reporting with with as
new policies get rolled out
i think that's really very helpful and
in my in my mind i'm thinking that
probably
even within my course syllabus i know we
have some language right now about
diversity but i think they're maybe
within my
syllabus i need to have some sort of a
disclaimer that although the forums are
meant for classroom discussion
um that that i
as i will report any concerns
to
that i feel have come up so that that's
the part where the trust comes in with
the student is feeling this is a closed
group
and yet you've you know you're like
obviously i'm concerned about it i'm i'm
nervous about it because there's been
a couple of times that i'm like ooh this
this is concerning and that's the reason
why i've contacted the student you know
individually but i appreciate your
comments because i i kind of believe in
the low threshold myself
so thank you very much um
sorry uh
uh you very much appreciate the
conversation actually having taken your
class i just wanted to
potentially like contribute
uh
to this specific topic
in terms of
um
the concern that
um
that
for anyone who is
sharing in
the class and the
um
that a
there
i don't know that there is
specifically
the uh
the specific mandatory need
to report everything
except whereas
permission has been given to
report like as you had previously been
doing in terms of contacting
students and obviously that could change
like if you
add that caveat
to that
but
um
from
like a lot of the issue with the trust
i believe is not trusting
the higher levels like they may trust
you with that information but they may
not trust the people you would report to
but i think that's a really important um
uh perspective to to to bring about
i guess as a and by by the way i've
heard that the comment about not
trusting the higher levels i've heard
that many many many times and frankly it
i have i also have concerns about that
to be to be blunt but i guess i would
say the following
um as long as the expectations or as
long as the um
it's clear that these conversations
should not be considered confidential
uh then i then i think that would be a
path forward if there is an expectation
implied or
inferred that that oh this is a safe
space in that way and that this is
between just between quote a group of
students and a faculty member
then i could see maybe think about this
differently but but i will say
um
the only confidential discussions are
with the confidential advocacy program
other than that you should not you
should i i think of it this way then
maybe this is a not a good way of
thinking about it but i'm saying i think
about a classroom conversation is
occurring in an elevator
it is not private
great um we're just about out of time
there's actually one more question in
the chat from one of our postdocs
um
who i don't know if you can see there
but um thanks for your talk and sharing
your wisdom george what would you say is
the function of toxicity in medical
institutions such as ohsu
i'm not sure what is meant by the
function of toxicity um i certainly
think that the the climate is toxic
uh and i'll point to two
pieces if you will so one of them is the
national academies
i think it's been now three years
national so
medicine science and engineering um um
provided a report about mistreatment uh
primarily gender focused um and the
number the data was
rampant it's unbelievably high in the in
in the sciences
um so
um so we have a toxic culture
that um
propagates mistreatment so that's that
would be part one of that um uh the sec
the second piece
is
um and this is my opinion so you can all
just
blame me i'll take full responsibility
for this uh i think that that we
um are
blinded to excellence
or percent perceived excellence
and so we will tolerate a lot of bad
behavior for
luminaries
prestigious individuals um the big
grants the big publications the big
discoveries and um i'll i'll close with
this because i'll never forget this
about three or four years ago anita hill
as in famous for the clarence thomas
hearings
for the supreme court anita hill was the
keynote speaker at a meeting of the
association of american medical colleges
double amc
um
and
uh this is a room full of deans and you
know high level administrators like
hundreds of people that were that were
at this meet this national meeting when
we could gather in person and anita hill
basically said
how many of you have actually dismissed
a nobel laureate because of sexual
harassment
and you could hear a pin drop and she
said
said your silence
is telling
and so the culture of excellence frankly
is code for
um we value that more than we care about
our people
great
well i want to be mindful of everyone's
time um so i want to thank george
actually as you're speaking i'm thinking
of the um
lander the scientists who
resigned yesterday um so maybe that type
of behavior won't be tolerated again
more but i want to thank george for
coming and sharing this with us and and
hopefully
giving some additional energy to our
committee and and again um everyone in
the department is welcome to take part
and
maybe as we make more progress and move
further along we'll have the opportunity
to chat with george again about this and
especially as things evolve
at the school level i appreciate it i
know time is up here bill but let me i
guess i should say one final thing this
will be short this is most of what i've
said um is read the reporting stuff that
was written about or
my own personal opinion i think what's
important is for everyone to lean in we
need to hear all the voices i certainly
do not believe that i am
right i'm certainly unconsciously
incompetent
thanks
okay thanks a lot um thanks george
thanks
thank you
in the end we'll we'll try to uh capture
your questions